النشطه المدنيه الايرانيه السجينه نرجس
محمدي هي واحده من ثلاثه ناشطين حقوقيين
تسعى مؤسسه اوليف بالما السويديه لتقديم
جائزه لها
وقد قالت محمد في رساله كتبتها وقراها
زوجها ان جهاز القمع في الحكومه الذي
وصفته بالاستبدادي اغلق الطريقه على مدى
الاربعه واربعين عاما امام اي حراك سياسي
واجتماعي وذلك من خلال القمع الشديد
المعارضين والمحتجين واحتواء صناديق
الاقتراع واصوات الناس
وانتقدت محمد ايضا سياسات النظام الايراني
الاقليميه والدوريه مضيحه ان النظام
الحالي في ايران لم يهدد تحقيق
الديمقراطيه وحقوق الانسان فحسب بل ايضا
السلام والامن والتنميه في البلاد
والمنطقه مشدده على انها تدافع عن حقوق
الانسان وتسعى الى السلام